- In 2020, Egyptologists
from the University of Bonn
deciphered the oldest known
place name sign in the world,
dating back to the late
fourth millennium B.C.
The four hieroglyphs inscribed on a rock
in the Wadi el Malik east of Aswan, Egypt,
declared the region the Domain
of the Horus King Scorpion.
Of course, place names,
otherwise known as toponyms,
existed far before the Scorpion King,
both the 2002 and the 3070 B.C. versions.
But where do place names come from?
Well, toponymy reveals a lot
about the culture and history of a place,
including the people who lived there,
the nature of the settlements,
and the geographic landscape.
So that's your short answer.
For the long answer,
including the longest
place names in the world,
join me as we dig into the
exciting world of toponyms.
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky,
and this is Otherwords.
(mysterious music)
- [Narrator] Otherwords.
- I love superlatives more than anyone.
So the first thing I wondered was
what's the longest toponym?
Growing up, I thought it
had to be the nearby lake,
commonly called Webster Lake,
but officially named
Lake
Chargoggagoggmanchauggauggagoggchaubunagungamaugg.
The name comes from the Algonquin language
spoken by the Nipmuc people
indigenous to the area
and is said to mean
lake divided by islands
or fishing place at the boundaries.
At 45 letters, it's quite a mouthful,
but while it's the longest
place name in the US,
and the longest lake name in the world,
there are a few other places
that have it completely beat.
According to Guinness World Records,
Thailand's capital holds
the crown for longest name.
You might be thinking, "What, Bangkok?
That's shorter than Los Angeles!"
Well, Bangkok is actually
a colloquial name,
most popular with foreign visitors.
The locals usually call it Krung Thep,
which means city of angels,
and is a shortening of the
official ceremonial name,
Krung Thep Mahanakhon Amon
Rattanakosin Mahinthara Yuthaya
Mahadilok Phop Noppharat
Ratchathani Burirom Udomratchaniwet
Mahasathan Amon Piman Awatan Sathit
Sakkathattiya Witsanukam Prasit.
In English, that's "city of
angels, great city of immortals,
magnificent city of the
nine gems, seat of the king,
city of royal palaces,
home of gods incarnate,
erect by Vishvakarman at Indra's behest."
But that's several words, isn't it?
To find the longest one word place name,
let's head further south to New Zealand,
where there's a hill the Maori have named
Taumatawhakatangihangakoauauotamateaturipu-
kakapikimaungahoronukupokaiwhenuakitanatahu,
which means the place where Tamatea,
the man with the big knees,
who slid, climbed, and
swallowed mountains,
known as landeater,
played his nose flute to his loved one.
Not to be confused with a nearby hill
where Tamatea, the man with the big knees,
who slid, climbed, and
swallowed mountains,
known as landeater,
played his accordion to his loved one.
Just kidding, I made that up.
If those are the longest place names,
what are the shortest?
Three letters? Two?
Believe it or not,
there are more than 40 places worldwide
named with just one letter.
You've got your A, E, I, O, U, and Y,
with various diacritics,
but also D, G, H, L, and W.
Hey, easy to spell.
Then I wondered what's the
most common place name?
According to the US Geological Survey,
Fairview and Midway are competing
for the most common place name
in the United States,
with 288 and 256 locations, respectively.
But neither comes close in terms of number
to the winner of the title: San Jose,
with more than 1,700 locations worldwide.
The name is so common
likely because many of
the cities and towns
were founded by Spanish
speaking missionaries,
who chose the name St.
Joseph for his significance
to their faith.
In fact, the top nine most common toponyms
were named after saints.
History is built into place names.
Sometimes, it's as clear as a new name
because those who thought
they were discovering
slash colonizing lands
wanted a reminder back home,
hence, New Caledonia,
New Zealand, New Orleans,
and Nova Scotia.
There's also been a tradition
of naming these
questionably acquired lands
after colonial monarchs,
which is where we get all the
Georgetowns and Victorias.
Recently, movements to
throw off colonial names
and reclaim either indigenous
ones or new non-colonial ones
have become popular.
Limbe, Cameroon, for example,
was formerly called Victoria,
and there's been a political push
to add Aotearoa to New
Zealand's official name.
Interestingly, despite shifts in power,
due to say, invasion,
toponyms tend to be conserved,
surviving repeated language shifts.
The United States is full of places
that kept their Native American names,
even as the people who
named them were forced out.
In all over Western Europe,
we see cities with Celtic names,
like London, Paris, Vienna,
Milan, Ghent, and Zurich,
none of which are home
to the few surviving Celtic languages.
Even more specific history
can be baked into toponyms.
In the British Isles,
you can deduce a fair amount
about a location settlement
demographics from its name.
For example, Sussex is the
land of the South Saxons,
Buckingham is the home belonging to Bucca,
and Canterbury is the fortified
town of the people of Kent.
This type of naming tradition
based on residents is far from extinct.
Think ethnic enclaves,
like Little Mogadishu,
Tehrangeles, or Basque Block,
that are named after the global locales
that the residents immigrated from.
Native American place names may describe
not only local topographical knowledge,
but also information
about resources available
at certain times of the year.
Manhattan is derived from
the Munsee word, manahahtaan,
meaning place for gathering
the wood to make bows.
Massachusetts is derived
from the Wopanaak word, muswachasut,
meaning near the great hill
or at the range of hills,
and Mississippi is derived
from the Ojibwe word, misi-ziibi,
meaning great river.
Occasionally, a place name no longer
reflects the current landscape.
Back Bay in Boston is a bustling
metropolitan neighborhood
but has the name of a
water feature, curious.
Well, history tells us
that it used to be a bay
until it was filled in in the mid-1800s,
but the name stuck.
What about Wall Street?
The actual street,
not the metonym for big
business or financial markets.
Wall Street in New York City
has a bull and fancy buildings,
but no wall.
The street was named for a
defensive wall built in 1653
that was removed less than 50 years later,
yet somehow that legacy still lasts.
Inspiration for toponyms can come
from history, myth, climate,
geography, and more.
But most important,
they're a reflection of
our shared experience
on this planet called Earth.
Before you go, we're
looking for your feedback.
Each year PBS Digital Studios
conducts an audience survey.
It helps us understand what you like
and what you wanna see more of.
You also get to help PBS pick new shows.
It only takes a few minutes,
but your feedback is
extremely valuable to us.
There's a link in the description.
Thanks in advance.
Udomratchaniwet Mahasathan
Amon Piman Awatan Sathit
Sakkathattiya Witsanukam Prasit.
Yes!
- [Man] That was great.
- (laughs) I'm happy with that.